quantum break let's have a little chat
Peter brand yeah let's have a child of a
quantum break yeah ah six out of town
gamespot com excited 10-2 at a five on
giant bomb com two out of five eight out
of ten itn 8.5 on polygon and Game
Informer Jim starting as well Digital
Spy give it a sweep 5 out of 5 and yeah
I want to talk about this because I've
been playing quite a break for the past
couple of weeks and when your review was
going through QA I was like yep yep
totally I'm like talking to Jeff about
it he was like I think probably bit more
down on the combat but he was yeah yeah
otherwise it was like yet that seems
about right and then I saw I don't know
like our scale isn't as we tend to use a
lot more of it than the most sites but
when I saw the other reviews I was like
wow okay yeah I don't want to like cast
any like any negative you know opinions
towards any of those were other
reviewers because they've truly like the
game that much cool but yeah I was just
it was like did I play a different game
did I did I miss something here ah but
yeah I think people are having very
different reactions to this and it's
interesting to me that like I had spoken
to jeff a little bit about his opinion
but it was but it was mostly like the
day before publishing the review because
I was like I'm really anxious people are
gonna get really upset with me and I
just need to know are you in line with
me because if you're not then I should
be anxious but yeah it was like no I'm
not okay I'm not alone but then it turns
out we're alone me and him are the two
that are the outliers and we work in the
same building and I don't I don't know I
what people see in this game like they a
lot of people describe the similar same
problems that i had with it which are
which are Oh like hmm let's get into a
little bit for contacts for the people i
don't want to just rattle off a list it
deserves more explanation so where would
you like me to begin pick a piston
aspect of the game and I will tear it to
bits okay let's talk about the most the
most important thing about the game
which is the movement combat moments
moments gameplay in terms of like what
you're actually doing and controlling
the main character yes movement feels
like you've got 20 pound weights on you
20 your feet there maybe Mike you're
going through mud maybe that's
accurate is slow it is unresponsive it
is loose and you know you're getting
into combat scenarios where yeah you
have these time powers that help you
move around quickly get advantages on
the battlefield and stuff like that but
at the same time there are moments when
that's taken away from you and you have
to resort to using just your basic
mobility and it becomes so clear at that
point that something is missing and
that's something that's missing extends
to when you take cover like this is a
game that yeah maybe you don't want to
call it a cover shooter but you're lying
to yourself because any time you go up
to anything that is waist-high you duck
behind it automatically okay you take
cover mmm like most of the engagements
in this game evolved you taking cover or
if not running from cover to cover it i
get it right absolutely a coverage right
it's imperative because the only way to
recharge your your time abilities which
allow you do various things is to take a
break and let them you know it's cool
down time or that kind of thing so you
know and your health recharges as well
same thing so you just you go hide you
get some health back your powers back
and you keep going but when you can't
use your powers and you want to use your
gun from cover you don't have you don't
have the ability to blind fire yeah you
have to stand up no matter what to fire
your weapon therefore exposing yourself
i I'm gonna pull no punches here it is
ridiculously stupid that that was a
design decision that made it into this
game I remember I really have said it to
me and I thought oh this never came up
for me and then later that day three
times somebody flanked me and I couldn't
just shoot them crying I had to stand up
and that eight people shoot at me I
think it was matinee I don't even want
to hear the argument that this game
isn't designed to be a shooter because
then why the hell do I have guns and why
the hell am i forced to use them at some
point and also that happened to me way
before I got any of the other powers
which kind of mitigate that like the
ability to like run fast later in the
game there are these machines that
literally strip you of your powers right
yeah it's not even you don't have access
to new things you don't have anything
you got nothing but your guns and the
fact that you have to get shot just to
shoot somebody when you're trying to
protect your son i'm totally with you on
the movement and like even the aiming
everything about it just feels like you
know that killed zone think that's like
the easiest elders that people say that
kills only felt very heavy in the aiming
was it was heavy or whatever um I like
actually for whatever reason that
actually was
because I was 5 grand theft auto 4 which
is another 12 people say some 3 was
pretty good right but this one was
something about it just feels yeah it
does not feel like oh this was meant to
be shooter first no it'sit's is well
yeah I mean I don't think it is
necessarily but I said that's a very
strong component of it and the aim
assist feature is turned on by default
and I turned it off mizu no I need it
like I'm ineffective without it and I
don't think it's because of me like I
feel like it's because like the game
presents you with scenarios with a
certain level of stress and threat you
have to react in a certain amount of
time and this game is doesn't really
afford you the ability to do so with any
amount of skill yeah so at that point
the auto-aim just becomes like a thing
you need and the the powers themselves
although like you can sort of guess what
they are it was like a bubble shield
which app so you regenerate there's one
that like stops them in a time bubble
City you can load them full of bullets
but like none of they are seem desperate
like none of them connect to each other
or you can't really change em any sort
of interesting way I so I I think Jeff
described a similar thing to me but I I
kind of disagree like I found a really
good rhythm during combat well you can
upgrade your powers and the differences
aren't incredibly noticeable when it
comes to the moment-to-moment stuff of
chaining different moves together being
able to increase the frequency with
which you use an ability during a charge
made a difference for me so I was able
to you know zip across the field kappa
time shield kasto time shield you know
put a bubble out there shoot that guy on
my shield ran out zip somewhere else
behind cover and then you know just kind
of like mix those abilities together and
I I found that two pretty fun the combat
is pretty easy your powers are they make
you very opie the game only goes so far
as to introduce you know big bad guys
that have a weak point in their back
yeah um which I'm not that difficult to
think that they're all that difficult to
take down by the shock there AI is its
glow they don't put their brought their
yellow right yeah yeah okay and they
have the same monarch logo on absolutely
everything in this video yes but yeah
literally everything is a giant head
we're the bad guys are cool okay yeah
you miss security guard stuff like these
hoodies with em like sewn into like what
the time maybe we're getting too picky
here but like no we're not no we're not
I've got sport that's dude come on no
that's awful
it's not the real world they're trying
to present this really dramatic
situation set in the real world of
people actually have real life problems
that are a part of the greater struggle
in this fantasy and then they have goofy
henchmen it's just like that just pull
you right out of the experience so the
other like like sort of the main like
cancer or the main dramatic pull in this
game I'm not sure we should talk about
this necessarily is the fact like that
time is going to end for one reason or
another it's kind of a bit like I I
never felt worried the time was going to
end the best agents get the open listen
I it's just yeah i know there's like a
spoiler that it's literally the first
thing that happens in the game so let's
talk talk about but like even then like
the main thing you should be worried
about in this game strips away thrown at
the window like almost yes I at no point
did I have any investment of whatever
dread was being communicated to me on
screen by the characters yeah it felt so
contrived if it was one part actually
where the there was so much emotion out
of the character because he was about to
like leave this mission me done and he
got off ticket went up to like a valets
like key yeah like you know world puts
all the keys and he's like yeah and he's
like valet box every car thief's dream
and he like picks one easily and like
gets in a Ferrari or whatever and drives
off and it's like did you just murdered
a bunch of people and also isn't time
about to end like why are you just being
this like cool cat yeah no I mean and I
guess ties back with the uncharted 3
somebody so the thing about this is i
want to talk about is that like
obviously people rated the game
differently right yes and i'm just
interested why because it's so broadly
different and to me this is a game that
is very like I'm right with you where it
is fine it is the main reason I think
that it comes off as more than fine is
that it's really well presented oh yeah
like it looks great from the best
looking games of the year and like it's
got Reno decent like voice act even
though like the scripting isn't
particularly great there's something
like you know quality quality of
qualitatively whatever good about it it
just it feels like money's been pumped
into it an effort has been played yeah
but in even if it hasn't resulted in
something great it's like even a TV show
it's kind of this plotting ridiculous
mess but I kind of love it because it's
so weird
I love it because it's and I love the
glass every time I had to watch an
episode yeah I'll say that yeah it's
less than that's interesting and none of
the characters seem to have anything to
do with the main story really in any way
but I feel like a lot of people raised
it really well because it looks nice
like it's because it comes across as a
game with a big budget and lots of like
yeah I know I noticed we're behind even
if it's actually just like a you know
it's right not a well-polished heard I
want to say that it's a fine game but
it's not something great game by any
means a game to Kim at ten years ago
yeah I mean I saw people dumping on the
game dumping on the show you know
calling them middling and then me live
but oh man I've never seen a game do
something like this before and that and
that influenced their assessment and you
know if that actually made them enjoy
the experience more that's totally fair
hmm I it's the same reason I can't give
a game kudos just for being in VR you
know it's there are doing something
novel is only good when it's put to good
use and here I don't think it was put to
good use did you like Alan Wake I didn't
play alan wake okay so i really liked
Alan Wake yeah because it kind of struck
this interesting narrative like corded
me and I was like oh okay like I mean
I'm in with this guy like it's kind of
crazy what's happening and it's cleverly
written and all this and like this feels
like they tried to take the sort of
charming you know nuanced storytelling
of Alan Wake and apply it to like a
mainstream audience with more CSI style
and television stuff and it just it's
just like not there's olas there's no
neurons it's basically like guess what
time is in play and weird stuffs gonna
happen and you're not really gonna know
what's now or later or the before go
have fun like but that's that's kind of
the extent of it like it's all this this
doubling back on what you thought you
knew because time travel is a thing yeah
Oh am I completely wrong or does the
whole time broken thing also feel like a
massive MacGuffin and that like it never
actually makes any that there's no
through line like it just seems to be
like at certain points timed out time
did something and then it's just to
serve the narrative like yeah I don't
feel at all like I feel like somebody's
going to take this story and break it
down and be like none of this has any
consistency
like maybe I'm wrong maybe loads of
thought went into it but even now I
don't like I have no because I haven't
completed each other my time yet near
not the end but like I feel like this I
don't have any clue what the rules of
this world are it's just like press Y
here to make the bridge go back so you
can walk across it like why can't I do
that everywhere then why is it only
happen in places which are part of your
platforming thing why it's why can you
only use your powers in some sections
but not others there were times where I
was in an environment looking for a clue
and it was like okay the room is so big
and I walk so slow I'd love to zip over
there oh I can't use my powers now not
because there's a device like in combat
that negates it the game just decides
yeah you don't need those right now we
want you to walk over there and we want
you to move slow enough that you notice
the other items in the environment and
it's so sad that a game which takes such
a and I feel like it sounds like a bring
very critical but we are also yesterday
yeah I guess it just feels like it's
kind of a missed opportunity is that the
other thing about this game that feels
crazy old like how can you have this
many pic like a narrative objects in a
world that are just pages and pages of
text yeah I like gosh the story does not
at least for me it did not warrant the
amount of time that it required for me
to like get the finer details of the
characters and their plan arcs in the
story it was to me just a ham-fisted way
to take the characters from the show and
put their stories into the game you know
apart from any sort of social or
professional connections that they had
to the main characters like you'd find
it an email from the do that's only in
the show and it's forever long yeah and
you read one and you're like okay that
was kind of interesting how geez there's
like ten more in this room mm-hmm I
think I'm gonna move on I think I'm
gonna walk away from that yeah but then
I talked to some people who were telling
me like oh did you find this one thing
oh it was great and it's like I believe
it i wish i had found that but it got
lost in a sea of dribble yeah i thought
i also i'm a big fan of the remedy TV
show stuff they do yeah and stuff and
this one just wasn't i found like three
of them so far i think and yeah it's
just not great either it's kind of like
oh you guys are bedded miss baby but
yeah and i would really like to talk
about the distribution of activities as
i constantly refer to it as so this game
is a TV show this game is combat this
game is narrative sequences and it is
platforming yes and
it's basically all divided evenly hmm so
the one thing in the game that it does
incredibly well is well I'm not moving
out incredibly well but one thing the
game does well as combat right second to
that is this I grief the the
storytelling stuff that happens between
action sequences when you're walking
with the character from one point to
another and even though you're not doing
anything special you're just walking I
found that to be a good break to just
sort of like taking some exposition and
dialogue in these characters very well
produce those sections as well like
there's a reason why they showed
basically that's all they ever showed in
previews they were showing it at events
for years right and that stuff is cool
yeah but then you know you expect okay I
just got through this story I'm ready
for more action and then you got to do
some platforming and it's like oh you
got to find the dumpster to climb on to
the roof to jump over to the next roof
to climb down the ladder you know and
make time go backwards before the
building was built walk in and make time
go forward done yeah but you only have
five seconds to do it and you have to
wrestle with the horrible mobility
controls to get the thing done in time
but it's all it's also all scripted so
you can only climb certain objects yeah
yeah even though there's something that
would make your past simpler to complete
this game is screwed up man like there's
one thing where you had to rewind time
to make a van yes out of a ton so I was
when you said that I literally thought
there's a part where yeah I want to jump
on the van but no I have to do this
whole thing to make there is a van that
is seven feet tall you are a freaking
time wizard you've done you've climbed
on top of things taller than that in the
game you can't just climb up on the van
you have to reverse time so it can back
up so you can jump off of a roof to get
on top of it yeah like II illogical BS I
when a game does stuff like that it to
me it assaults my intelligence right and
it assaults my time because it's like
look I'm not here to do this basic [ __ ]
yeah give me some give me some make me
feel like you understand what makes a
good game don't pat it out with things
that nobody wants to do and nobody will
believe is like a thing that has to be
handled in that way yeah just it's so
padded with BS did you say insult your
intelligence our US soldier until I said
assault I just get so much more powerful
praise yeah yeah that's good seriously
like a writer some so if people want to
see the full review I don't make our
column week sorry quantum break is that
today quantum week consequat
I'll kwanzaa break is that today I I
think it's gonna be very interesting to
see what like people who buy us i'm
looking at metacritic user reviews are
mostly 10 really yeah well I can but I
know it's like been out for like six
hours that's Xbox one owners who this is
like one of their own II sort of big
games is coming back and it does look
really good on Xbox one yeah like for
all the complaint 90 separation that's
yeah you know the game looks great it
has some good moments some stores on the
goal play yeah but like the the mesh
that holds it all together is fractured
in far too many places it's just
unreliable it's very widely linear game
hey listen Peter the only thing I wanna
know uh are there and what is the
quality of the time puns in the game oh
no I don't remember there's lots is
really there goes there ought to be did
a break the fourth wall and like wink at
the camera because I don't remember any
of that we're running out of time maybe
they already do that all the time oh man
does i'm not sure if they mean it half
the time there's one more point we have
to address okay the last point other
than time but the fact that this game is
designed to provide multiple paths for
you to pursue and thus encouraged you to
replay the game yeah the things that
change are so minor yeah again it's like
an insult to like you as a person who
has the same ending tomorrow wash game
it yeah some characters are swapped out
some yep but none of it yes if it ties
into like your story for the most part
its just oh it's just tried differences
that mean nothing so they go yeah
quantum break 6 out of town against wall
comm check out the review it's a real
fair game real fast super fair it's a
super fair game if you've played it
yourself lettuce on time has passed and
you have to just burn through and your
fam way let's know what you think in the
comments below but yeah very interesting
to see see what the fall ash will be
from this one
you